the protesters identified this police
station pretty much unprotected and they
attacked they encircled the entire
building systematically smashing the
windows of cars parked near the
station's fence this is a massive
escalation in this already violent
crisis others hold bricks inside this
was designed to provoke the police who
had kept off the streets for the entire
day of protest in Hong Kong's Kowloon
district news quickly spread that riot
police had been deployed within minutes
the first teargas round started coming
in they knew it was coming of course but
as is always the case it causes panic
and a surge to get away from the gas
clouds filling the streets
demonstrations the right places a
decided enough is enough and they're
coming in now they're firing a tear gas
into the crowd try and move them away
from this police station that they've
basically been proceeding for a long
time they've got a very low presence
throughout the day but I suppose it was
inevitable as they the night grew that
they were going to come out of the
police station there's another one
further down that road they intend to
clear this crowd away and there are
still thousands upon thousands of people
out here the protestors coughed and
spluttered as they try to escape
others stopping to help those who are
overwhelmed by the gas and still it kept
coming
the demonstrators these days are
desperate to keep away from the police
for fear of arrest they attempted to
rebuild barricades as police units took
control of the entire area around the
police station a short distance away
thousands of young men and women
stripped building sites and erected
barriers across some of Hong Kong's
busiest roads this underpass leads to
Hong Kong islet the road was completely
closed and so was the tunnel now this is
completely unheard of this just doesn't
happen in Hong Kong well it didn't it
does now two months on the Hong Kong
authorities know they have a real
problem here throughout the weekend and
into next week demonstration like this a
plan they take all day and once again
the numbers are huge the demonstrators
ignored the routes agreed with the
authorities this was about causing as
much disruption as possible the main
shopping routes through Kowloon were
brought to a standstill by the protest
march and it stretched a few miles to
the city's waterfront even the
world-renowned Peninsula hotel was
keeping its doors closed all ages take
part but it is predominantly young
people they are emotion about this the
complex relationship with Hong Kong and
China is always not everyone supports
these demonstrations and many will be
appalled at the behavior of some of the
protesters but the numbers on the street
are impressive and there is no end in
sight the barricades will keep moving
but the battle lines are drawn it's
difficult to see when this will end or
how it will end without more violence
stewar aunty Sky News Hong Kong